et pour évoquer cette impasse en
guadeloupe patrice abdallah est en
direct il est secrétaire départemental
du syndicat unité sgp police fo bonjour
patrice abdallah merci d'être avec nous
ce matin sur la route
il a un peu plus de six heures du matin
en guadeloupe comment s'est passé la
nuit quelle est la situation ce matin
dans les rues de pointe à pitre ce qu'il
ya des tensions encore ou bien est-ce
que c'est un calme précaire
alors comme la nuit de jeudi à vendredi
les violences ont continué des pillages
et des violences ont continué donc
des forces de l'ordre ont été pires
encore a paraphé par par les jeunes donc
effectivement comme vous l'avait bien
dit un dans votre reportage une
dimension sociale cependant la cin qui
sévit dans ce département en particulier
à cause d'une pasta nitel l'obligation
vaccinale donc elle a dégénéré et a
continué à digérer et on croit que ça
continue concernant tôt crescendo
puisque la nuit de jeudi à vendredi
bailly les échauffourées et de la nuit
cette année dernière il ya encore eu des
échauffourées
vous venez d'employer le mot vives
tensions sociales on se souvient de la
grève de 2009 qui avait paralysé la
guadeloupe pendant 44 jours la
martinique pendant 38 jours à l'époque
avait pas de passing pas de pass à
lithaire pas d'obligation vaccinale mais
c'était plutôt le coût de la vie qui
était trop cher puisqu'on peut y voir un
parallèle comme vous avez dit la tension
sociale avec un ras-le-bol général qui
s'ajoutent aux revendications sanitaire
est ce que c'est triste peut durer aussi
longtemps qu'en 2009 est ce que vous
créiez une situation similaire c'est à
dire faut se parer à toute éventualité
parce que tout y moi en particulier ce
sont six principaux points d'achoppement
les pasta littéraire obligation
vaccinale nous avons encore d'autres
sujets qui sont son tour de ceux de ses
sujets et donc cette tension ali et lila
et palpable il ya de nombreuses de
nombreux sujets de
revendications dans le département de la
guadeloupe et ceux ci vont fait
qu'aujourd'hui
nous retrouvons donc dans cette
situation mais néanmoins il va falloir
trouver une situation
mission par rapport à cette situation
anarchique et un sur insurrectionnel pas
dire ce grand désordre dans lequel se
trouve la guadeloupe se doit cette
situation se doit de ses six et la
situation la solution à laquelle vous
zappez justement est-ce que ça peut
passer par la négociation certaines
formations politiques ainsi que des
syndicats réclament des négociations
dans tous les cas tout en oeuvre que ce
pays retrouve son l'odeur de ses
victimes et surtout que le dialogue on
tira le dialogue toute sa place tandis
qu'une discussion du moment afin
également de permettre à tous les
citoyens de pouvoir aller venir comme
bon leur semble parce que c'est
pénalisant de ne pas pouvoir se déplacer
de ne pas pouvoir aller travailler et
aussi qu'on reparte aussi notre économie
qui est aussi fragilisé et d'autant à
l'approché des fêtes de fin d'année
patrice abdallah vous avez dit qu'il ya
eu d'ailleurs encore cette nuit le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
on voit qu'ils étaient policiers en
renfort ça veut dire que les forces de
l'ordre guadeloupéennes sont dépassés
dans quel état d'esprit sont vos
collègues face à cette crise je veux
vous dire que ça fait plus de deux à
quatre semaines voire plus que nos
fonctionnaires sont sur le pont parce
qu'il ya eu des manifestations va dire
ainsi fini il faut quand même d encadrer
donc alors aujourd'hui que cette
situation a dégénéré il est plus que
nécessaire de sont retrouvés
aux adhérents dont on n'a pas perdu le
contrôle de la situation mais pour
permettre à ses fonctionnaires justement
dessous c est à cet effet rien dire que
nous demandons à ce qu'au ministère de
l'intérieur des moyens et renforts
conséquents terrain de fonctionnaires de
police et dans leurs enfants épisodique
c'est pour ça que je vous ai dit que la
tension était palpable dans le
département
cette solution d'envoyer 200 gendarmes
et policiers n'est pas suffisante
surtout que cissé épisodique il faudrait
vraiment un renfort conséquent dans ce
département sur le coup nous réclamons
depuis depuis très longtemps sur le long
terme donc il ya une autre décision qui
a été pressé la préfecture qui a annoncé
un couvre-feu pour faire face à la
montée des violences quel impact réel de
d'une telle mesure
l'impact réel je vous dire que ça permet
justement de de juguler licencieux
voilée aux aînés
des tensions encore cette nuit oui non
mais cela n'a pas freiné les tensions et
encore il ya des pièges bien cette nuit
y'a quand on dit ils sont encore pris
aux forces de sécurité pour l'instant
que des informations concernant le la
commune de pointe à pitre effectivement
les fonctionnaires de police pendant 2
22 heures à 4 heures du matin en rendit
a
décidé de
sécuriser la jud le protopic we7 pas
sans peine parce que enfin on a eu un
collègue de blessés et celles tenues et
donc il ya eu des pillages de magasins
qui ont été pillés il ya eu lieu ils ont
essuyé les fonctionnaires de police ont
essuyé des jets de pierres donc
ce couvre-feu à permet au
prêt permet de préserver la population
qui se boit normalement de rester chez
eux mais on n'empêche pas ça n'a pas
empêché à aux jeunes oh je ne voyais ou
de pouvoir être à l'extérieur il de
pouvoir vouloir en découdre avec les
fonctionnaires de police vous avez
procédé à des interpellations
à l'heure actuelle je n'ai pas
l'information des poules
en soit j'aime tout arrosé pour le
moment j'ai tout à l'information pour
ici merci patrice abdallah d'avoir
répondu à une question je rappelle que
vous êtes le secrétaire départemental du
syndicat unité sgp police fo